Once you can place cones and cylinders, another handy method to write is one
that creates capsules, also known as cheese logs. A capsule is simply a cylinder
with a sphere covering each end. You can build up some pretty interesting
looking objects using cheese logs. Here's the interface for a capsule. The
capsule function is again, fully documented in the code itself. For this
exercise, I've implemented the simple part, positioning the cylinders, and I've
given you the code for how I want you to create the sphere's geometry. Your job
is to efficiently add spheres to the end of the cylinder. The open top and open
bottom Booleans determine whether or not a sphere is added. If you need to add
two spheres, one to each end, please use instancing. In other words, make a
single sphere geometry object, and reuse it for both ends. When you're done, the
scene should look like this. Notice how some of the cheese logs touch, and only
one sphere of a particular color is rendered at the intersection. Now, on to the
exercise.